hey guys Dave and Gina back at
Roseanne's kitchen table what are we
doing here find out right over here
there's a thing right here so I want to
talk about grass-fed butter in coffee
this is known as a bulletproof coffee
everyone's doing this out here in LA we
love the trends out here and I've been
doing it for a couple months so
bulletproof coffee is organic black
coffee beans grass-fed butter which
means you have to feed at the cow butter
because that can be very people go
grass-fed butter how do you feed butter
to a Daddy feed right you know butter to
grass or grass to butter got it so you
feed the cow grass and then it makes
butter and then medium chain
triglyceride oil I got it right well and
then you put in your coffee and you get
a burst of light of omega-3s and these
are the good healthy fats that
everybody's talking about
people used to say all fat is bad for
you but that's really not the case and
it does some good stuff it's like oiling
up anyway so I've been doing grain lube
I've been doing some organic grass-fed
so what do I do I do organic coffee from
Trader Joe's like 79 $7.99 can then I do
1 tablespoon of grass-fed butter I do 1
tablespoon of coconut oil which is you
it's really really good for you and I do
like half a tablespoon of manuka honey
which is this really good honey and I'm
telling you it has changed my life it is
like a slow burst of energy throughout
the day instead of that coffee higher
than the crash because it actually
supposedly the butter causes it to seep
into your system slower that makes sense
because the fact slows it down and
you're getting all this good stuff in
your brain so you're not we've talked
about it yeah I haven't done it but the
first time I ever heard about it and I
hadn't heard anyone talk about it I
posted it on Facebook and got an
onslaught of just disgusting you're
disgusting you're a terrible person I
hate you unfriend so now it's like a
thing that people are doing and I need
to get on board I don't drink coffee
because 15 minutes later I'm under a
table like shaking and drying and with
the grass but this makes sense yeah and
I also know I have friends who give
their infants like a pad of butter just
to kind of like suck on because it's
supposed to help your brain the brain it
makes
you get a little but that's why I'm
telling you it's kind there's something
about coconut oil particularly you feel
like cuz it's kind of oily on your right
like you feel like you're like putting
good oils in your system to get the day
going and that sounds amazing and I
would like to get on board but I do have
a very personal question for yes when
one combines a potent liquid caffeine
and two forms of a real rich oil yeah
what times that set to go off as a
friend of mine would say uh you know
what I'm on I'm on a pretty regular
schedule so I get up at about 7:30 it's
gonna happen around 9:00 o'clock it's
not just gonna be one disaster after
another I mean it's not like this sounds
like it could be a tricky little game
with this but I mean I don't have to
drink it on the toilet if that's what
you're asking
pretty sure is what you're asking
yeah but like you're okay great is not
done if anything it's made it a little
smoother a little smoother you really
went there
I've asking the questions that people
want answers to I promise you know the
other thing people are doing with
coconut oil have you heard of oil
pulling yes where you literally just put
coconut oil your mouth and you swish it
around for 20 minutes it's done I did it
once it supposedly makes your teeth
white and it's good for your gums and
then you have to spit it out because
it's it's sucking all the do you buy
this stuff like when these Bad's come do
you buy them no I don't know I don't
want to be a hater like they all sound
interesting him yeah give it a try no I
don't think it can hurt you yeah but I
just like I'm one of those people just
with clothes and clearly I am NOT like
one too I I'm not trying to set any
trends so like you know one thing though
like one dietary thing that you do that
you feel like you're getting do you mash
kale into your yes all of it I'm a [ __ ]
into every everything yeah I have been
juicing for a long time my secret
because I just I don't it's not a meal
replacement because there's so many
sugars in fruits and in carrots and
certain vegetables yeah that if that's
your meal or said you're gonna spike and
you're gonna drop and you're gonna go
yeah so what I do is I loved you saying
now I love
the taste now but that is my beverage
for my sensible meal ah so it's not you
know I don't know I don't power it down
you know after a Big Mac but with like a
salad or with whatever that is my
beverage so it's not a meal replacement
that's a big one for me well I'm gonna
work on getting Gina to suck on some
butter what are you guys doing any weird
health related things that you're doing
do you believe in any of this goji berry
acai berries all that good stuff
basically anything that Oprah says is
good that everyone buys let us know the
comments right down below